[Applause]
e.t can confirm american idol winner
lane hardy has been arrested for
allegedly planting a listening device in
a female student's dorm room at
louisiana state university
according to booking documents obtained
by et on friday the country crooner is
charged with leaving a listening device
in his ex-girlfriend's room in order to
monitor her conversations when they
broke up
the two reportedly dated from november
2021 to february 2022 and according to
the docs she found the device which at
first appeared to be a phone charger
under her futon and later learned it was
a voice-activated recorder e.t has
reached out to hardy's reps for comment
but on thursday the 21 year old singer
shared his own statement on facebook
acknowledging that the lsu pd issued a
warrant for his arrest due to
allegations made against him and while
the ai alum didn't say what he was being
accused of he did note that he was fully
cooperative with cops adding that he
understands his career thrust him into
the public spotlight something he says
he embraces wholeheartedly however due
to the sensitive nature of this
allegation i humbly ask for privacy at
this time i have the utmost respect for
the law and will assist in their
investigation as needed moving forward
according to the docs hardy allegedly
had information about the victim and her
actions during christmas break that was
not known to the defendant
and when the female student confronted
hardy he allegedly admitted that he left
a bug in her room but later discarded it
in his pond
[Music]
the singer won season 17 of american
idol back in 2019.
my mind is so overwhelmed right now with
so many different emotions
and i really need to
let it sink in it hasn't sinked in yet
i'm still processing it but it's been a
crazy ride and it's been a lot of
tough situations and a lot of mental
stress and stuff and
it feels i feel it feels great and e.t
was with hardy earlier this month at the
great idol reunion where he opened up
about returning for the show's 20-year
anniversary celebration this is a huge
milestone for american idol and like
being part of their 20th year
anniversary is going to go down the
history of this show so it's pretty cool
to be part of it best piece of advice
for people coming on to american idol
trust your gut and stay open-minded
[Music]